.
THESE DOCUMENTS NEEDED TO BE
SUBMITTED JUST BEFORE MIDNIGHT
AND THEY WERE.
KARA, GIVE US THE LOW DOWN.
>> RIGHT.
JOHN, WHAT WE'RE REALLY SEEING
IN THIS DOCUMENT IS DOJ
PRESENTING A COUNTERNARRATIVE TO
THE NARRATIVE THAT TRUMP HAS PUT
OUT THERE.
THEY SAID WHAT HE HAS SAID WAS
INACCURATE AND MISLEADING AND
THEY GO METICULOUSLY THROUGH
SOME OF THOSE DETAILS THAT SINCE
THEY EXECUTED THAT SEARCH
WARRANT THEY RECOVERED TWICE
ADDS MANY DOCUMENTS AS THEY HAD
RECEIVED WHEN TRUMP AND HIS
LEGAL TEAM HAD RESPONDED TO A
SUBPOENA.
THEY ALSO SAID THAT IT'S LIKELY
THAT A NUMBER OF THESE DOCUMENTS
WERE CONCEALED AND REMOVED FROM
THE STORAGE ROOM THAT THE FBI
INITIALLY WAS ALLOWED TO ENTER.
THEY SAY THE FBI AGENTS WHO WERE
THERE WERE NOT ALLOWED TO OPEN
ANY BOXES IN THE STORAGE ROOM
AND THEN THEY SAY THAT THEY HAD
LEARNED SOME EVIDENCE AND INTEL
THAT PROMPTED THE SEARCH
WARRANT, THEY GO BACK IN AND
THEY FIND THREE DOCUMENTS IN THE
DESK OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
DONALD TRUMP.
SO THEY'RE SAYING THERE IS A LOT
OF POTENTIAL EVIDENCE HERE THAT
THERE WERE EFFORTS UNDERTAKEN TO
TRY TO OBSTRUCT THIS
INVESTIGATION, THIS EFFORT TO
OBTAIN THESE DOCUMENTS, THAT
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR BECAUSE THEY
ARE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
NOW, ALSO TO THE LEGAL ARGUMENTS
HERE OF, YOU KNOW, SHOULD A
SPECIAL MASTER BE APPOINTED.
PROSECUTORS ARE SAYING THESE
AREN'T TRUMP'S RECORDS, THESE
RECORDS BELONG TO THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, THE U.S. PEOPLE AND
THERE'S NOT GROUNDS TO DO THAT
HERE.
I MEAN, IT'S A VERY DETAILED
FILING AND IT GIVES US SOME NEW
INSIGHTS INTO THE WHOLE TIMELINE
IN THE PROCESS HERE THAT WE
NORMALLY WOULDN'T SEE IN AN
ARGUMENT OVER A SPECIAL MASTER.
>> THIS IS REALLY THE FIRST TIME
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS WRITTEN EXTENSIVELY SINCE
THE WARRANT WAS EXECUTED,
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN RELEASED
TO THIS POINT HAS BEEN THE
WARRANT ITSELF, THE REDACTED
AFFIDAVIT, THIS IS DOJ TELLING
US WHAT THEY FOUND.
IF WE CAN PUT THE PICTURE UP
AGAIN SO PEOPLE CAN SEE HOW THE
FBI LAID OUT THE DOCUMENTS ON
THE FLOOR.
ELLIE, FIRST GIVE US YOUR TOP
LINE ABOUT THIS RELEASE.
>> IT'S DOJ STRIKES BACK.
CLEARLY DOJ HAD SOMETHING ON
THEIR MINDS, SOMETHING WAS
BUGGING THEM AND THEY USED THIS
FILING TO UNLOAD ALL OF THAT.
WE SEE NOW, BY THE WAY, WHY THEY
ASKED FOR A DOUBLE LONG FILING.
THE FIRST THING THAT I THINK YOU
TAKE OUT OF THIS FILING IS THAT,
FORGET ABOUT THESE QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER DOJ ACTED TOO
RATIONALLY, TOO SUDDENLY WHEN
THEY EXECUTED THE SEARCH
WARRANT.
THEY HAD NO CHOICE.
I MEAN, KARA JUST LAID OUT THE
EXTENT OF THE TIMELINE AND HOW
LONG THEY WERE MISLED AND LIED
TO BY TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS, HOW
MANY CHANCES THEY GAVE TRUMP'S